i thought it was
pretty cowardly kind of pretty bush
league
which
you know there's plenty of tape out
there to watch i haven't seen it replay
but yes i really haven't seen it
anything like that yet
i'm fine i'm good good to go
that's mason rudolph after the game
after he's hit in the head with his own
helmet and fortunately he's fine which
is also very fortunate for miles garrett
because i think the punishment would
have been worse if there would have been
a severe concussion inflicted on a guy
who was knocked out cold last month on a
hit from raven's safety earl thomas
let's hear what mike tomlin the coach of
the steelers had to say after the game
when he was asked about that moment that
happened with only eight seconds left
i'll keep my thoughts to myself you guys
saw what happened at the end
you have no comment about it that's
exactly what i said i got no comment
have you ever seen anything like that at
the end of the game no more questions
regarding that because i'm saying
nothing
here's why mike tomlin said nothing and
also the steelers pr people were doing a
very aggressive job of getting their
guys to zip it quickly so they didn't
say much about what happened now marquis
pouncey had some things to say i mean
some of it was unavoidable there was a
memo that was sent by the league october
11 2019. i got i have a copy of it here
the gist of it was don't criticize
officials and we've seen a couple of
players gets get fined because of it
baker mayfield was fined 12 500 for
public comments criticizing officials
clay matthews had a tweet unrelated to a
game he was even playing in it was the
lions packers game with the trey flowers
illegal use of the hands hands of the
face penalties that got clay matthews
upset he got fined for the tweet at the
bottom of this memo it's clear that
league policy prohibits public criticism
of opponents you cannot make accusations
or criticism of opposing coaches or
players etc and i think the steelers
keenly aware of that so in that moment
they know look these are things that we
can't air out publicly if we've got
issues with what happened we need to
take it up with the league through the
proper channels and i think mike tomlin
to his credit in the moment understood
if i go all in on the browns at this
podium i'm gonna have an issue with the
league office and i think that's why for
the most part the the venom that that we
heard from the steelers was somewhat
muted and add on to that mike mike
tomlin has two guys in this uh situation
that might be facing suspension
themselves and that's mason rudolph and
marquise pouncy so anything he says in
this post-game press conference could
then be shown as him being a hypocrite
if he goes and blasts miles garrett and
says you can't do any of this stuff
after the whistle or after a play well
again miles garrett was the was kind of
the guy who went too far but marquis
pouncey started kicking miles garrett in
the head after the play when they're in
the end zone so i think he did a good
job of making sure he didn't uh say
something that could then be used
against him when talking about his own
players and what they did in the in in
the brawl
and pouncy said after the game that he's
sort of blacked out in the moment and
look
and this gets back to the point you were
making and this doesn't mean i'm
agreeing with your point but there's a
moment where
that that
that command kicks in almost
unconsciously you got to protect your
quarterback you got to protect your
teammate and once somebody crosses the
line as far as miles garrett does we're
in uncharted territory here we don't
know how the other human beings are
going to react in that moment when they
see an opponent remove the helmet of the
quarterback and whack him in the head
with it and i think what marquise
pouncey did big cat is what a lot of us
would do in that situation when we see
it go that far i mean what do you do do
you just you take a step back and say oh
that's an unfortunate development or do
you jump in and try to keep it from from
getting worse and in the process you
become an aggressor and here's what i
can guarantee you today this morning i
guarantee you that the members of the
cleveland browns locker room are
disappointed in miles garrett because
they know he's going to be facing a
suspension for a long time he lost his
cool and he's one of their best players
i guarantee you that the guys in the
steelers locker room love what marquis
pouncey did because he stood up for his
teammate
and in that moment yeah he went too far
too but it does feel a little different
because he was standing up for his
quarterback who just got bashed upside
the head with a helmet
and miles garrett still had his helmet
on at the time i i still
and there's nothing funny about this
stuff but i always chuckle i always
chuckle when someone punches someone in
the head who's wearing a helmet you're
not going to inflict any damage on him
you're only going to inflict damage on
you when you punch a helmet
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports